[Music]
in the summer of 1895 crowds flooded the
Coney Island boardwalk to see the latest
marvel of rollercoaster technology the
flip-flap railway this was America's
first ever looping coaster but it's
thrilling a flip came at a price the
ride caused numerous cases of severe
whiplash neck injury and even ejections
all due to its signature loop today
coasters can pull off far more exciting
tricks without resorting to the thrill
of a hospital visit
but what exactly our rollercoaster is
doing to your body and how have they
managed to get scarier and safer at the
same time at the center of every roller
coaster design is gravity unlike cars or
Transit trains most coasters are
propelled around their tracks almost
entirely by gravitational energy after
the coaster crests the initial lift Hill
it begins an expertly engineered cycle
building potential energy on a sense and
expending kinetic energy on descents
this rhythm repeats throughout the ride
acting out the coaster engineers
choreographed dance of gravitational
energy but there's a key variable in
this cycle that wasn't always so
carefully considered you in the days of
the flip flap ride de signers were most
concerned with coasters getting stuck
somewhere along the track this led early
builders to overcompensate hurling
trains down hills and pulling on the
brakes when they reached the station but
as gravity effects the cars it also
effects the passengers and under the
intense conditions of a coaster
gravity's effects are multiplied there's
a common unit used by jet pilots
astronauts and coaster designers called
g-force one g-force is the familiar tug
of gravity you feel when standing on
earth this is the force of Earth's
gravitational pull on our bodies but as
riders accelerate and decelerate they
experience more or less gravitational
force modern ride designers know that
the body can handle up to roughly
five g's but the flip-flap and its
contemporaries routinely reached up to
12 G's at those levels of gravitational
pressure blood is sent flying from your
brain to your feet
leading to lightheadedness or blackouts
as the brain struggles to stay conscious
and oxygen deprivation in the retinal
cells impairs their ability to process
light causing greyed out vision or
temporary blindness if the riders are
upside down blood can flood the skull
causing a bout of crimson vision called
a readout
conversely negative G's create
weightlessness within the body
short-term weightlessness is mostly
harmless it can contribute to a rider's
motion sickness by suspending the fluid
in their inner ears which coordinates
balance but the bigger potential danger
and thrill comes from what ride
designers call air time this is when
riders typically experience seat
separation and without the proper
precautions ejection the numerous belts
and harnesses of modern coasters have
largely solved this issue but the
passengers ever-changing position can
make it difficult to determine what
needs to be strapped down fortunately
modern ride designers are well aware of
what your body and the coaster can
handle coaster engineers play these
competing forces against each other to
relieve periods of intense pressure with
periods of no pressure at all and since
a quick transition from positive to
negative g-force can result in whiplash
headaches and back and neck pain they
avoid the extreme changes in speed and
direction so common in thrill rides of
old modern rides are also much sturdier
closely considering the amount of
gravity they need to withstand at 5 G's
your body feels five times heavier so if
you weigh 100 pounds you'd exert the
weight of 500 pounds on the coaster
engineers have to account for the
multiplied weight of every passenger
when designing a coaster supports still
these rides aren't for everyone the
floods of adrenaline lightheadedness and
motion sickness aren't going anywhere
soon but today's redundant restraints 3d
modeling and simulation software have
made roller coasters
and more thrilling than ever our precise
knowledge about the limits of the human
body have helped us build coasters that
are faster taller and loopy er and all
without going off the rails in terms of
human evolutionary instincts
rollercoasters don't make a lot of sense
so what makes us love them check out
this lesson on why some people love to
be scared
[Music]